today is Earth Day and thousands are
expected to take to the streets to call
for action demonstrations are planned
from Washington to Los Angeles and
around the world to raise awareness
about the science of climate change
which many say is under attack in this
country Alaska is emerging as ground
zero for the impact of the
administration's proposed environmental
funding cuts larry peterson went to the
country's most northern point to take a
closer look with temperatures soaring
this last winter to 50 degrees above
normal the area around the North Pole is
melting and the Arctic sea ice is
shrinking at a rate never seen before
we're talking about something that's got
to happen in the next decade Jeremy
Mathis is director of Arctic research
for NOAA the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration the Arctic is
warming twice as fast as other parts of
the planet we met mathis at Oak key avec
Alaska the farthest northern city in the
United States where Noah has a lonely
outpost monitoring the Arctic sea ice
here on the polar ice it's not what you
see but what's hidden below the ice is
thinning it used to be nine feet thick
in some areas now it's more like three
why do I care about what's happening out
there we care about the Arctic because
it has connections to the entire
northern hemisphere to people down in
the lower 48 states the warming Arctic
is causing the jet stream to wobble
across America helping spawn massive
weather events and as America's weather
becomes more destructive early warnings
become more critical but scientists may
lose their vital tools let climate
monitoring satellites targeted by the
Trump administration Mick Mulvaney is
the administration's budget director as
to climate change we're not spending
money on that anymore we consider that
to be a waste of your money John Walsh
is chief scientist at the International
Arctic research center and the
University of Alaska in Fairbanks
they're basically ignoring threats to
the well-being of future generations in
Alaska warmer temperatures are
melting the permafrost villages are
literally disappearing and scientists
say Alaska today is fair warning of the
climate change future for the rest of
America for CBS this morning saturday
Barry Peterson key avec Alaska